ciertamente no será un partido que se
recordará en el tiempo pero para los
generales es poco importa porque han
logrado esa ansiada primera copa
africana de naciones de su historia
dejando atrás los fantasmas del pasado
esos que le marcaban que en 2002 y en
2019 esas finales habían terminado con
derrota esos fantasmas si se quiere se
avivaron cuando en el minuto 6 de
partido salió mané la gran figura
senegalesa no pudo aprovechar un penal
por una falta de abdel moneim sobresalió
sis que podría haber cambiado un poco el
curso del encuentro el delantero del
liverpool terminó rematando su penal en
levemente sobre la derecha pero con
fuerza pero no muy esquinado y fue el
arquero de mohamed alí al dabbagh y como
se le conoce quien contuvo el penal
ese parte es el gol quizás hubiera
cambiado un poco el desarrollo de un
partido que estaba planteado con egipto
muy cerrado en defensa como han sido la
mayoría de los encuentros de los
dirigidos por carlos queirós apostando a
un partido largo a llevar a ir
desgastando senegal que tomó la
iniciativa en los primeros minutos se
mostró con más entusiasmo y generó
algunas situaciones de gol pero siempre
chocó con el arquero gabás que tuvo un
par de apariciones en mohamed salah
también en ese primer tiempo en las
situaciones en las que podría haber
abierto el marcador poco a poco el ritmo
del partido fue decayendo senegal se fue
desgastando egipto nunca se despegó de
su plan llegó la prórroga en la que
senegal volvió a tener tres ocasiones
claras todas por bomba día en uno de los
que había ingresado en el segundo tiempo
y siempre se impuso el arquero gabás que
parecía el escenario planteado para que
otra vez se convirtiera en héroe este
arquero que entró en los octavos de
final de manera inesperada por la lesión
de mohamed el shenawi y que ha sido
clave para la selección egipcia atajó
uno de los penales en la definición
justo después de que abdel moneim
fallara el suyo pero finalmente no hubo
lugar para la para ese es el lugar de
héroe para cámaras que fue el arquero de
eduard mendi el mejor arquero del torneo
el mejor arquero del mundo actual el
portero del chelsea quien contuvo el
remate el cuarto de egipto y salió
mantuvo su revancha con el quinto
disparo anotando con un fuerte remate
esta vez es bien esquinado sobre la
derecha de gavà aquí para poner el 4 a 2
en los penales y darle ese trofeo a
senegal y también a su entrenador al
yush dice muy criticado en la previa de
este torneo y que le permite a los
senegaleses festejar esta primera copa
africana de naciones que podrán ofrecer
a su público en dakar mañana según lo
que han comentado los propios jugadores
después del partido cuando sea el
regreso medio la capital senegalesa muy
bien cede y una vez acabado el torneo
que balance en general podemos hacer
destacan ha sido un torneo que quizás
desde lo futbolístico no no ha dejado el
mejor rendimiento no ha dejado un equipo
que sobresaliera al respecto del resto
por lo menos no demasiado pero que sí ha
tenido sus sorpresas y sus decepciones
por el lado de las decepciones
ocurrieron sobre todo en el inicio del
torneo con la eliminación rápida del
campeón defensor argelia de gana de
equipos importantes que fueron quedando
en el camino y las sorpresas han sido
esas bellas historias que construye
selecciones como como horas o gambia
debutantes que avanzaron más allá de lo
que se esperaba línea ecuatorial también
que se metió entre los ocho mejores del
torneo esas pequeñas historias han
animado y equipos que incluso con su uso
de pocas armas se animaron a jugar
fueron parte de las buenas historias de
este torneo desde la organización
una organización claramente marcada y
atravesada por el cómic 19 con las
restricciones que se impusieron para el
acceso de los estadios que provocaron
que no siempre los escenarios estuvieran
llenos de público pero sí se notó en las
calles ese clima festivo de sobre todo
el público camerunés que esperaba a su
selección en la final no pudo hacer se
tuvieron que conformar con un buen
tercer puesto finalmente para la
selección de tony conceiçao pero termina
redondeándose entonces esta organización
de la copa áfrica de naciones que espera
a su próximo torneo muy pronto en 2023